le canada a remporté l'or carey price
quelle performance il a fait alors oui
martin mcguire carey price quelle
performance il l'a fait aucun but un
match parfait pour lui un autre en fait
hier lors de cette grande finale et bien
un retour remarqué à montréal de les
voir y est un peu fatigué beaucoup
d'heures d'avion mais très content
olivier à rebours masse et à une quatre
heures après le triomphe
le sourire était plus modeste affaibli
par une nuit de voyagement la fierté
elle est intacte son humilité habituelle
n'a pas changé malgré l'or olympique
carey price c'est carey price + en clair
souligné le travail de ses parts qu'à
s'étendre sur ses exploits de gardien
par excellence du tournoi d'acting lui
aussi a fait son effort de guerre
il a blanchi les américains en demi
finale et a fait le même coup aux
suédois au match ultime
roy petit but accordé en cinq matches
est-ce que ce sera suffisant pour faire
taire ses détracteurs une fois pour
toutes
pour l'entraîneur des gardiens du
canadien price fait partie de l'élite
aucun doute là dessus j'ai béni mellal à
commentaires de bab de mike babcock
il explique confiance c'est exactement
ce que ne rapporte pas seulement une
médaille d'or de ce chien pendant deux
semaines il a côtoyé legends tales et
autres sidney crosby
les gagnants de la coupe stanley et
surtout price sait maintenant qu'il peut
battre les meilleurs un atout redoutable
avec taio rien comme ça l'était plus
demain parce que tu sais que maintenant
tu peux battre dans l'équipe c'est parce
que tu le fait avec nate à tahiti puis
c'est pas un problème ça m'a fait
beaucoup rire
sky is the limit ici olivier rebours
masse radio-canada droit ça